good day everyone and welcome
i'm jack van horn from the university of
virginia please allow me to welcome you
to our 2020 2021 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar series
working previously with colleagues
through the nih's big data to knowledge
program
we began this seminar several years ago
with the goal providing a foundational
resource for the theory
practice and applications of data
science and biomedical research
now based at the university of virginia
we are now continuing this seminar
series
with a focus on the data science and its
particular applications
in thematic biomedical topic areas the
theme for this year
is the brain and the data science
necessary to process
analyze model integrate and interpret
brain form function
and connectivity across scales in health
and in disease
the variety and richness excuse me the
variety and richness
and scale of neurobiological data types
increasingly necessitates
novel data science methods advancing uh
data processing
data mining statistical analysis and
synthesis
and visualization are all needed to make
this make progress in the neurosciences
to characterize complete and
come up with more comprehensive
neurobiological systems
these are be important for the
identifying the most efficacious
treatments for development
neuropsychological and neuropsychiatric
diseases
as well as syndromes which affect the
brain as we age over the coming weeks
we'll present a blend of lectures on the
basics of data science
brain science and their intersection
these videos are being streamed
live via youtube are also being recorded
and will take their place in a corpus of
foundational video content concerning
data science applications
in biomedical sciences please share the
youtube channel link with your
colleagues your students and
other interested stakeholders in
beginning this year's seminar series
i'm pleased to welcome professor don
brown from the school of data science at
the university of virginia
who will present his appropriately
entitled lecture how to do
data science donald brown is the
founding director of the data science
institute at the university of virginia
the co-director of the integrated
translational health research institute
of virginia
i thrive and the quantitative foundation
distinguished professor and professor of
data science
here at the university of virginia which
is the first
such school of its kind in the united
states focused on the subject of data
science
dr brown is a fellow of the ieee and
recipient of the ieee joseph wall
career achievement award for his work in
systems engineering and data fusion
he conducts research in predictive
technology data integration machine
learning
and simulation operative optimization
with applications to health science
security and to safety our innovation
lab
participants should be able to submit
questions for dr brown via their zoom
chat feature i
will synthesize these and present them
to dr brown for discussion
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
seminar
with that uh welcome don we are very
much looking forward
to your lecture well thank you very much
jack i appreciate that
very nice introduction um so i'm going
to jump right into it as to how to do
data science and i'm going to start with
telling you a little bit about the
school of data science at the university
of virginia
because that gives a background to what
we're going to be talking about
we call it a school without walls and a
comprehensive university and by that we
mean that we are
we reach out we're not uh we're not like
a lot of
data science programs that come out of a
single department
uh for instance a statistics or computer
science department
nor are we one that come out of the
joining of two departments or within
a single school we are in fact a school
that
exists on its own and it reaches out to
all schools at the university
and we have another 11 schools at uva
that we reach out to and in doing so we
try and leverage the research and
scholarship of those other schools that
we have at uva
in order to to create a data science a
set of data science programs
and to conduct research in data science
we've been advised by business
government and academic partners and
that's what's given us
a sense of what data science should be
in the world that expands these areas
business government and academic
institutions we also coordinate a lot of
the
all of the teaching uh in data science
across
these disciplines across uh programs
throughout the university
and we created new educational programs
particularly in the master's program but
we now have a
phd program that's uh that's under
review and we have a
an undergraduate program that we'll be
rolling out soon as well
as well as an undergraduate minor that
is already in place
we enhance we also enhance the hardware
and software infrastructure
that supports data science
okay so um let's start out with a little
question about what is data science and
it started out with the idea of what is
big data
and when there is this great joke that
big data is like
teenage sex everyone talks about it
nobody really knows how to do it
everyone thinks everyone else is doing
it
so everyone claims they are doing it and
uh this is this is sort of the
underlying joke behind the area but uh
that dan nearly had it's a very a very
nice little uh way to uh to think about
what we're about and a lot of
institutions
uh but to get more serious uh
what is data science well uh actually
data science has been a
field or topic of discussion in academia
and
uh business and in government for a long
time well at least since the 1960s it's
been
definitely in papers that people have
talked about data science
in 1998 wu gave a very interesting talk
in michigan where
he said that really data science and
statistics but since then
and frankly even then most people didn't
believe that and in fact they
felt that it's it's uh quite different
it's
aryan in and of itself but what is that
area in and of itself
well let's take a look at some uh some
some things that others have written
about what data science is
a concept to unify statistics data
analysis machine learning domain
knowledge related methods
in order to understand and analyze
actual phenomena
and this is what hayashi said also in 98
and then you've got this one from leak
the key word is data science not
data it is science data science it's
only useful when the data are used to
answer a question
and then we have dar who wrote that data
science is a study of the generalizable
extraction of knowledge from data
and low who said data science is a
multi-disciplinary blend of data
inference
algorithm development and technology in
order to solve
analytically complex problems now i
could give you more and more of these
things but i guess the point i'd like to
make is that there are two
central concepts that come out of just
reading all but uh wu's
initial uh comment there are two things
that sort of run
through all of these definitions and as
i say there are many more i can give you
that
these two concepts also appear in i
think
for a moment and see if you can uh and
see what those two concepts are
and if you if you have them write them
in the chat and i'll
i'll try and take them as uh his input
to this
but think about what uh what those two
areas are and i guess it
as you're thinking about it notice that
uh
we have in a lot of them this unifying
of multiple areas okay
blend of data inference algorithm
development technology
so this idea of
integration of fields uh
interdisciplinarity
runs along a lot of the ideas of what
data science is
and the other thing that runs into it a
lot of them is this idea of
analyzing actual phenomena answer a
question
okay solve an analytically complex
problem
these are the two things that we're
going to focus on because those that we
consider to be at the heart of what data
science is
so let's take the first one data science
combines disciplines
there are a lot of sort of these venn
diagrams of data science that
they try and capture this idea the data
science is an interdisciplinary uh
activity i'm giving you one of the very
simplest of these and they're a lot that
are very complicated some that are quite
funny
but they're the basic ideas is that data
science seems to be about
bringing together a number of areas in
order to answer a question
and there's there's another version of
it we like to say data science as a team
sport so you can think about all these
different areas all these
interdisciplinary areas coming together
around
the idea of trying to solve a data
science
question and that's that's at the heart
of a lot of what we think about in data
science is this
notion of bringing together these
different fields in order to solve the
problem
and the other aspect as i say is the
solving of a problem
how do we how do we we need to solve a
problem
so it's you know again uh one version of
it is it's extracting knowledge
in order to do this okay in order to
solve a problem
but fundamentally then if you once you
understand okay it's great it's uh this
interdisciplinary approach
and it's focused on a particular problem
there's this is a very application
oriented field
the question then is how do you do it
how do you go about doing this
um and i i love this quote from tukey
because it really gets it
the frustration you can he pointed out
the combination of some data
and an aching desire for an answer does
not ensure that a reasonable answer can
be extracted
from a given body of data so just
because you know you've got the data and
boy you really want to solve the problem
and you've got all these different
fields
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to
get an answer and you're going to get
the answer that you're looking for in
particular but you're
that you're going to be able to solve it
you've got to have something else and
that's something else is you need to
have an approach you need to have a
a structured way to go about the problem
in order to get an answer
and that's what we're going to talk
about throughout this talk is
how do we go about doing that well one
of the earliest ways that people
presented for doing data science was
what was called the cross
industry process for data mining or
chris dm
and it represents this process flow it
says you start out with some sort of a
business because this was a business
oriented uh
group that came up with this idea they
were they were looking at as a business
understanding but you could think about
this
in general you could think about this as
the understanding the health
sciences application that you're working
on
data understanding and trying to
understand what the data have in it then
you do the preparation the wrangling all
that kind of stuff
then you do the analytics or the
modeling the evaluation of your results
and then you
communicate your results through
deployment
and this method really does describe a
lot of what it is that we're about when
we think about data science
but we were somewhat dissatisfied with
it because it implies a process flow
that doesn't really get it the way that
a lot of us
work on data science problems and one of
the key insights came from a colleague
of mine
when we were we were looking and we
looked at probably uh 15 or 20 of these
things and then
i'll give him credit he noticed the idea
that you can actually fold them one on
top of the other so in fact
you could bring this data understanding
uh
business understanding you can look at
this as one area you could look at
data understanding and deployment you
could fold them back on each other
data preparation as well bottom line is
is that we
we came up with a different way to think
about it that we think really captures
more about what data science is about
and we call this the four plus one model
and the four plus one model is the four
major areas
in these four areas are value design
analytics and systems these are the the
four areas that we consider to be the
critical parts of data science and
operation
and at the center of it is this notion
that i said
is critical in data science you're
solving a problem and we call that
practice
uh you're solving a problem for some
real application you're trying to answer
a question
and that's the bull's eye and this in
this notion that's the
plus one that's where we're looking it's
it's in the middle because it
it's the key focus for all areas that
we're working on
the four areas represent the four key
aspects of data science
and then the the center point represents
uh what we really want to keep in mind
at all points so it intersects with
everything
that we're trying to solve a problem for
some organization
in the real world now i'm going to talk
about those intersection points and you
can see you've got concrete human
abstract
i'm going to postpone talking about
those for a little bit and and go into
some of the other
the specific the four areas here
um so that we have a better definition
and the first one we think about is
value
and what value does is it represents
this combination
of both ethics and business planning
it's bringing together
uh and again you can replace business
with organizational planning or
organizational understanding
what is it that we're we're after what
what
is the what is the problem that we're
having to deal with
and how does that relate to the
organization how does it provide
value to that organization how is it
moving that organization
forward in some way and at the same time
what are the ethics what are the
what are the values as they relate to
the ethical
concerns around the problem that you're
dealing with
and there typically are those and every
problem we deal with
we come up with these kind of issues and
we need to we need to
deal with them up front and center in in
doing data science
and they're the these these other points
there's policy making organizational
motivation
all these things are part of this value
component
a key part of the value step if you will
of the value
aspect of data science is the formation
of what we call a value proposition
where we describe specifically what
value
this or values this particular work is
going to bring
uh to the world into the organization
for whom it's done
there the one nice thing about this four
plus one model is
that we expose tensions and tensions are
good
tensions tell us that these are the
values or
these are the sorry the trade-offs that
we've got when we're working in this
space
because you can't work in in a space
like data science without experiencing
trade-offs
they're always going to be trade-offs in
the way that you perform this work
if you if you expose them and make them
explicit then you can deal with them in
a much more effective way
and clearly we have these tensions here
we have enterprise versus ethical values
another way private interest versus
public good
the organization has issues it has or it
has values it has
things that it wants to accomplish but
at the same time we have to think about
the larger values that we have to
society
or the values that we have to
individuals that for whom we're working
with in order to accomplish the data
science project
we have to think about these larger
societal values whenever we
we do a data science project as well as
the organizational values
for the organization that we're working
for
okay design the next component of this
four plus one model
design is the human centered part of
this this is where we really think about
the human being
interacting with the with the data
science piece this is where you really
look at what the data is uh as a data
science as a data
scientist or data analyst you're trying
to understand the data
you're the human trying to understand
what it is that you're dealing with
but it also deals with your your
customers your stakeholders
everybody that you're interacting with
the design component is all about this
human
interaction with the uh with the data
with the technologies
uh where the products of the
technologies where the products of the
data science work
all of that is what's involved the
little picture that i'm showing you is
this
typical way that we think about design
is it's it's actually
giving us ways to visualize a lot of i
mean visualization is a key part of
design
how do we visualize the data uh how do
we visualize the structures that we're
dealing with and
as a data scientist we want to
understand the data and visualization is
one very powerful way to do it but
as consumers of data science projects
our customers our clients our sponsors
they want a visual
visualization is a good way to see what
it is that you've
accomplished and in the examples i'm
going to give in this talk i'll try to
describe some of those
some key activities then in this area a
representation in communication through
database design
the curation of data as i say the
visualization of complex data okay the
display and visualization
and visualization of the analytical
results the showing of those results
tables we use a lot but we also use
visualizations
tensions discovery versus product uh
this is uh this is a major tension using
user facing versus analyst facing
another tension is it is it something
that the analyst understands and gets in
but the user has no clue the sponsor the
the clients they've got no clue what
you're talking about these kind of
tensions exist within the design
component
and uh and they're things that we again
we're aware of
once we make them explicit and we're
aware of them we can we can take actions
and deal with them
okay the systems framework is uh is part
of the uh
the data science i i i say this the the
two
the first two value i think people think
about but they
they don't necessarily think about it
the way that we've we've structured in
terms of this
both the value of the organization and
the value to society
and the value to the individuals that
we're working with
and design frankly a lot of people don't
really call out as a separate and equal
component to these other areas the next
two this one in particular
systems in the analytics piece people
think of
all the time when they think of data
science these are the ones that most
people
frankly firmly associate with data
science
the systems area is the area where we
think about the computation this is the
infrastructure that provides the support
for working with the data that we're
we're working the data that we need to
solve our problems
it includes not only the the structure
the the underlying
hardware but it includes the software as
well in particular
the pipelines to move the data to where
they need to be moved in order to
get the job done for us
we think of it as computational science
and technology
necessarily opposed to computer science
and the key activities here are really
developing
really this this infrastructure this
performant infrastructure that can
that can accomplish what we need to do
and we think about cloud resources this
is the the
name of the game today but it involves a
lot of other things
as well and and some of those are
mentioned here including the networks
uh the uh the
resilient uh pieces of this of the
network and the
underlying infrastructure and as i said
also the software
involved in accomplishing this the
tensions here we have development versus
production
because a lot of times there's
tremendous pressure to get production
systems out
uh as opposed to really spending the
time that's needed in order to build
the resiliency that we need and
maintainability in these systems
volume versus speed another major
[Music]
area of tension extensible versus media
these are the kind of tensions again
explicitly making everybody aware that
we've got these tensions as we go
through
it analytics when people
think of data science they add they
completely associate analytics with data
science
and it is an absolute it is a very key
element this is one of the major
the two major things that i think have
made data science what it is
frankly are the the this one and the one
that i just talked about
we now have the hardware systems that
allow us to accomplish
tasks that we were frankly impossible
before
and we have the analytical methods we've
produced the methodologies
today that can actually go after
incredibly difficult problems
so these two together have really
elevated data science to a major field
and made us what we are in terms of the
things that we can accomplish with
uh with the field so i'm spend a moment
here on analytics these are the
mathematical machine learning kinds of
things that we think about when we think
about data science
and it involves all these things there i
mean i can there's a long list and i've
only listed a few here
optimization signal processing neural
networks and i've got a picture of a
deep learning network on the right
these are the kinds of things that you
think of when you think about the
analytics but it
incorporates all aspects of this we are
bringing together
the the broad swath of analytical
capabilities that have been built
up and continue to be built i mean it's
an ongoing area it's
wonderful to watch and wonderful to be
part of to watch
uh what's happening in this area and the
tremendous
methodologies uh ex wonderful
methodologies that are being produced on
almost a daily basis
key activities here is obviously
converting this is where the
you know the rubber meets the road
taking the data and turning it into
something that's useful turning it into
the answers
to the questions that we we've got that
we've posed this is where it actually
gets done
is in this analytical part of the uh
data science structure that we described
the four plus one model so this is where
we're really
meeting the challenge that we've got the
tensions here there there are many of
them again i'm mentioning just a few
one of the big ones that people talk
about a lot is causality versus
correlation
and whether we need causality or whether
we can be satisfied with correlation is
correlation sufficient for us
do we really need to drive to causality
would do we need to understand that
inference versus prediction another one
that spun out
um prediction has been the the new
the new major uh evaluation methodology
that we see in data science but we
continue to rely on inferential methods
observation versus experiments uh
feature selection versus feature
engineering
how do we how do we pick and understand
the contributors the predictive
variables that are contributing to the
answers that we're seeing
and accuracy versus interpretability a
lot of problems
we can produce incredibly accurate
results but we've got no clue
we've done it through black boxes that
we don't understand and we can't explain
very well
so these are all issues these are
tensions that we have in the analytics
area
okay and and the last and as i say the
bull's eye in this whole process is
practice this is where the problem is
and practice is what brings everybody
together it makes the team
signs okay this is characterized by
everybody working together uh you know
you've got domain experts people
really really understand at a deep level
what the problem domain is
and they can help when working with the
uh people who are
deep into the data science methodology
understand
how to go after the particular problem
that you're you're
uh that you're going for um and so
you you work together in order to
produce uh these kind of the solutions
that are actually going to be
uh true solutions and not just
theoretical solutions or solutions that
get written up in a paper and never read
or uh you know not used but actually
translational solutions solutions that
make a difference and actually
uh help an organization advance
okay key activities contact with domain
knowledge and real world problems this
is uh
this it's all about actually digging in
and understanding
uh what it is that you you've got in the
area that you're
you're working uh what you've got at the
level of knowledge and what you've got
at the level of
data and what you've got at the level of
people who understand
the characteristics of those
tensions goals versus resources uh
this is this tension just exists in
every problem-solving domain
uh you've gotta you've got a lot of
ambition but do you have the resources
to go after it and
can you bring the kind of teams together
with the resources the teams need in
order to solve these problems
uh integration versus decomposition
uh typically you've got you know
analytics versus uh
you know synthesis and and this is
always
these kinds of things play out in many
real problems and data
science versus practical understanding
uh
when i i teach data science i try and
get my data science students to
understand that when they work in an
area
they can't expect that the uh their
subject matter experts in that area
are going to do everything they've got
to learn that domain they've got to get
in and understand it well enough
that they can communicate in a
professional way
with their uh um
uh with their data with their uh
colleagues
who are steeped in that domain and
they've got to understand it so that
they're asking
the kind of questions and working with
them in a way that's effective
and this this is a tension that exists
in almost every team
that goes after these data science
problems
okay so let me uh let me summarize a
little bit about this four plus one
model and see
with a couple of key points here first
one is that
this is uh not unlike these process
models that people have thought of and
uh
in terms of doing data science this four
plus one model is not a linear model
but we typically start with value okay
so it isn't like you go from value to
design analytics to systems
it's that we don't think about it that
way but we do
we do say that you start with value
there's
virtually we i can't think of any
problem but i'm
i'm not going to say never because it's
possible that you can think of a problem
that doesn't start with value but every
problem that i've worked in
starts with value that value component
is absolutely key
you want to understand the problem from
the perspective of the organization
what is it that they want to accomplish
what are their goals what are their
objectives but also
what are the ethical issues what are the
societal issues and impact upon those
goals and objectives
and how do they influence the way that
you're going to conduct data science and
the ways you think about it
okay another point is the way that we
tried to draw this
is visually to give you the sense that
practice intersects with everything
okay it's it's absolutely important that
whatever you do you're always thinking
about the problem
it's not it isn't again the problem we
have with those process models is
frankly
they give the impression that you do
that what we're calling the value step
the value proposition kind of piece you
do that
you get it done and then you forget
about it and move on to the next piece
uh that's not the way it's done here
this this is an intersection with
practice and this intersection with
practice means that you have to think
about that that
what you discover in that value
component as it as it
impacts on the question you have in the
practical area carries through in
everything you do
and your impact in your constantly
working with
people who are experts in the domain to
understand
the kind to understand the data science
piece as you go through it
and if you happen to be an expert in
this in whatever domain which i think
most of you probably are
you then are actually you're
intersecting at the value design and
analytics and systems area as well
you're
you're kind of coming from the middle
out and you're saying okay i'm gonna do
these pieces
um and that's great and that's the kind
of thing we want you to think about
is that that practice intersects with
everything
the emphasis is not always the same here
you could
some problems are going to emphasize
analytics more some problems are going
to emphasize
design there's some problems frankly
they don't care about analytics very
much they care about the visualizations
they care about the communications
aspects
which means they're very very focused on
design
and so in the and that's fine it isn't
that each one of these things has to get
equal emphasis in every problem
they're going to be problem dependent um
so don't don't think that there's this
suggests just i mean again
we draw it this way to emphasize that we
consider them all equal
parts and doing data science but they
they're not necessarily all equal in
doing a data science problem
okay the meaning of the boundaries uh
these things
all have uh interesting boundaries and
frankly i could talk and talk about this
uh four plus
one model and all the interesting uh uh
pieces of it
but i'm just gonna point out and i'd
like you to think about it
that when you look for instance uh at
the intersection between
or at the boundary i'll say between
value and design
that's it's a human boundary because
both of them are very concerned about
talking to people there the interaction
is with people more than it is with
i'd say uh uh analytics or with uh
with machines or things uh that are uh
that are solid
in the world this is about people
talking to people
is what that that intersection is about
both of those areas are very much
concerned about
this this human interactions
that's key to data science on the other
hand if you look at the opposite side
systems analytics they're intersecting
with the machine they're very much
focused on how what's the hardware
and the software that's on the and that
hardware gonna do for me
they're very focused on looking at the
capabilities of those machines in there
and how they're going to accomplish
their tasks again i'm using the machine
but machine
and i mean that as well in the software
parts it's on those machines
the boundary between uh systems and and
value is
concrete it's this is uh you you want to
make it uh very very precise
and understandable and it's uh and it's
concrete in the sense of language and uh
in uh communication between them uh
in terms of design and analytics it's
abstract we
write a lot of it is mathematical a lot
of it is pictures and graphs or displays
these kinds of things exist between
these areas and
and so these boundaries make a you know
they provide a little bit of meaning
of where these uh these four areas
overlap with each other and uh and have
and share commonness between
uh their activities
okay one thing that the four plus one
model does is it provides a way as
all process models do but the four plus
one again is not strictly a process
model
but it does provide what process models
do which is that notion of completeness
and coverage
have you done what you need to do in
order to get the data science question
answered
and that's what this kind of approach
does for you it allows you to make sure
that you've you've really
done due diligence there okay
i'm going to turn now to a couple of
examples i've talked at the
high level of what the what the four
plus one model is and how to do data
science with it i'm going to give you a
couple of examples now
as to how this is done i don't work in
uh
in neuroscience or in the science of
brain
but i i have a several health science
examples that i've worked on
and i'm going to describe those as uh as
examples of this
one of them is environmental enteropathy
which has to do with children and the
other one is adverse surgical outcomes
okay environmental enteropathy
environmental anteropathy is a
relatively newly classified disease it's
only been classified in the last four
years
it's a subclinical inflammation
inflammatory disease of the
of the intestine and if you look at the
right you can see this uh
this notion of what's happening here you
can see that
normally we have a on the left
we have a healthy uh representation
where
we've got lots of surface area that
basically can absorb
the nutrients that are that are coming
through and on the right we have
uh a non-healthy situation where we have
decreased electrolyte absorption we have
decreased absorption
generally uh so this kind of uh
the villi on the left are uh are are
healthy they're able and this this is a
this very very nice uh design that we
have
which allows us in a very small space to
have a very very large surface area
for this absorption and unfortunately in
the right hand side because of
a number of environmental conditions uh
it becomes diseased and
unable to absorb so this kind of
condition is associated with
malabsorption linear faltering and
stunting uh children with it uh
are stunted uh impaired cognitive
development reduced responsiveness to
nutritional intervention as well
so nutritional intervention of course is
the first uh
point that we take in in these children
frequently don't respond well
or at all to it and also they don't
respond to uh
immunogenic
and vaccination oral vaccination as well
okay what's the value the value
piece of this is uh is really very clear
uh half the global deaths uh in children
under five years are
attributable to under nutrition and uh
and thus the study of this is is of
tremendous value
uh it's a worldwide value uh to to
really understand what's happening here
uh not only to the individual countries
but also the world
we need to understand it we need to
treat this and you can see that it is a
something that's not a focus just in one
area but it's focused
in a number of areas throughout the
world it's an important concern
the ethical issues here clearly clearly
is in all health issues we need to think
about
the privacy and protection of the
patients that we're dealing with
and we also need to think about in this
particular case
research collaborations that are truly
collaborations and that are not uh
dominated uh you know as has
happened unfortunately where um
some countries uh you know you know say
our country
comes in and and tries to say this is
the way you should do things
this is a collaborative effort it's a
collaborative effort with the countries
in which
we're working in order to accomplish
these tasks and these kinds of
collaborative efforts are incredibly
important
in order to make these these solutions
lasting
and effective you can do all the great
data analysis you want but if you don't
create the kind of collaborative
infrastructure at the research level
and at the uh at the translational level
for getting these
these solutions implemented then it's
all for not
so it's incredibly important for us to
have these collaborations
uh and and to understand uh how to
create those collaborations at the
beginning
okay design we've got in this particular
case we had 100
this is one example we've got a lot of
these things but
give one example here we had 108
de-identified biopsies
and they came from a number of different
diseases celiac
environmental enteropathy and normals
okay or controls and the way that we do
this is that we
cut up the image as it's shown uh and we
we
we do this in order that we can deal
with it with the fact that it's a very
high resolution image okay um
yeah you can see see like in normal
biopsies where photographs
ee biopsies were digitized slides data
were augmented by a factor of 30
via rotation horizontal and vertical and
i show that on the bottom
there so you can see we we can rotate
these things
uh in order to get uh in order to
increase the number of data
elements that we have to work with in
our models
uh the patches then are from whole slide
images so we're going to we're going to
cut it up we're going to grid this thing
and we're going to look at patches
from the whole slide image because we
can't our our analytics can't deal with
the whole slide but we can deal with
patches from the whole slide
i'm going to mention this color
balancing in a minute but that's a
result of the staining and it's
it's a big deal for us in order to uh to
work on this problem
okay um so the pre-processing as i say
we first uh
we grid the image uh and after doing
that
uh we create these patches uh and and
some of those patches are absolutely
worthless because they're taking
pictures of nothing or very almost
nothing
and so we run that through a process in
this case it's uh
it's what's called an auto encoder in
order to do a clustering
and find the areas and the uh the
patches that are actually worth uh
using for our modeling approach uh and
this is a key part of
this design piece is understanding that
i mentioned the staining
uh hemotoxical aminos and staining
h e staining uh this produces different
colors
based upon the characteristics of the
underlying tissue
and but unfortunately those those colors
also depend on local conditions
uh in the labs and that creates a bias
uh and in our particular case for
example we had the only the
the normal we got from a number of
places including uh
the united states but we have no uh
environmental
enteropathy cases from the united states
so there's a natural
bias that can cry that can occur because
uh what we're what
what we're doing when we're doing the
modeling is just finding a color
difference represented by the staining
and not any real difference that exists
in the underlying tissue and that's a
problem
so we need to deal with that as part of
design and this is what's called color
balancing it seems to convert all these
images to the same
normalized color space so that we don't
have any bias
as a result of that the analytics that
we use we use convolutional neural nets
and i've got a picture there i'm not
going to go into the details this isn't
the talk to go and the details of
convolutional neural nets
but uh we that's with that that's what
we do these are the latest techniques
for
for going after these kind of images
these are what's called a deep learning
architecture
and we can employ it for this
hierarchical image classification
problem
these these layers are called feature
maps we can stack them together we can
do all sorts of cool things in order to
go after this
and the output then is actually a
probability of classification into one
of these
disease categories from the system
standpoint i'll just say that we
we create pipelines to process the data
we we use the cluster systems or
clusters of computers
we also use graphical processing units
or gpus
uh these are the latest or these are
things that have been around for a while
for for really the gaming industry but
they they're exploited by us because
they they work
very well on these uh for these deep
learning problems and they allow us to
really find
uh where the the knee of the curve is
when we're trying to calibrate our
models
so we're building an infrastructure
systems infrastructure that has those
capabilities is very important to us
okay at the other end when we get the
results we have a design
piece as well we have to show people the
results and
and the first table here shows the
results that we get
when we when we train on one color
balancing
approach and test on that same color
balancing approach
and you can see that we get very good
results we're getting uh
we're getting good classifications for
environmental enteropathy pretty good
for normal
and uh doing well as well for celiac
disease
and and we do it as well when we change
the color balancing in the test set
you can see that we uh that the approach
remains robust to these kinds of things
and that's what we're trying to show is
the the accuracy here
and the important thing is is that we're
getting better accuracy than
pathologists with environmental
enteropathy because it is a new disease
not well understood
and we're getting a it's robust uh to
this
color balancing problem that we
mentioned with the h and e staining
and that's the kind of result that we
like to see uh in these in these
approaches
okay uh i'm going to then shift to
another
example problem to show you the this uh
four plus one model
uh and this one is adverse surgical
outcomes and the uh the outcome we're
going to look at is aki
um the sudden inability of the kidney to
clean the blood of toxins
and you can see that it occurs in the
united states
uh with uh not as not an insignificant
amount of
cases 25 000 per year
um and i don't have a date there but i
think that was a
16 is when that last was recorded
um okay 20 24 to 48 hours to diagnose
using current methods you've got to
you've got to say that this is a this is
a potential problem really fast
uh the mortality rate increases uh as a
result uh requiring
a hospital five times uh during
hospitalization
so it's got to be diagnosed quickly
current predictive model for uh for this
uh
so what's the value value is is that the
current predictive model really is not
very good
it comes out of uh this model from the
society for thoracic
uh surgeons uh used only it uses only
pre-operative data it fails
to accurately identify at risk patients
and i'm going to show you that
uh in a little bit here with sufficient
time to prevent injury
the goal then the value here is then to
provide more accurate prediction of aki
for earlier intervention
so what you want is you really want to
do a number of things you want to
say something about creatine change you
want to say something about
rifle categories which is no
classification risk
injury failure or loss these are the
ways that it's currently thought about
in that
in that current model and the ethics of
this
are around the need again to protect uh
personal information and the you know
this is a
classic problem we have in the health
area that we may have
we may have something that is
misrepresenting the underlying
population
in in many ways we may not our patient
population may not be
representing the general population we
we're dealing with
we may uh build models that are
basically uh
only effective for certain classes of
patients and we we need to think about
this we need to think about the
stratification of our patient population
as we go into these
okay the systems area uh
we we've got a variety of machines that
we can use on it we've got large
clusters again we've got gpus
we need to do this rapidly uh and
provide the results in the operating
room if possible
there are there are three major areas
that we were looking at
creatine change rifle categories no
class
which says uh hey look do something now
or don't
don't worry it's okay and the approaches
that we
we're using again there's a laundry list
of
techniques that were that we that we
applied to these kind of problems
and they're listed on the right these
are analytical solutions that come out
of this whole bag
of tricks in the analysis area that have
been built up
in the last 20 or so plus years
to uh to go after these sorts of
problems and all of them were applied
here in order to try and understand
what it is that we were dealing with and
could we in fact solve these different
problems
the design the sadly uh we only had 5
000 surgeries in this
in the data set that we could work with
but even more sadly if you look at
missing data extreme values and mixed
mass mismatches between data sets
we ended up with only 335 that
could be used for the analysis so it's
this is a
a problem that we find all the time
again in the health area
that we need to work with and and we
also have imbalance uh
creatinine change is just showing you a
little bit of that imbalance that it's
it's it's imbalanced in certain ways
that that allows us
not to be able to to apply these models
as effectively
without doing other things we need to we
need to reach into a bag of tricks and
understand how to go at it
the design there's a lot of this in the
in the design area here that i
clearly this is just to tell you that in
order to do this
problem a lot of work was spent in in
order to get
the data to the point that we can
actually use it very effectively
i'm going to point out only one piece
here in the middle
uh and that's that in order to deal with
this this missing data
and uh characteristics we use
simulations okay we simulated
uh patient characteristics in order to
create
a more balanced training set that we can
actually use
for our results and that's a key part of
a lot of
again health problems you have to think
cleverly about how you can
you can build uh data that can be used
for uh for doing the analytics and
the design uh places where a lot of that
is where that work
gets done in order to uh to provide you
with the data
that you need for the analytics this
is just to show you i told you that that
sts baseline
the society of thoracic surgeons
baseline is not very good and this kind
of shows you that result
if you look here you see that their
model
basically predicts
renal failure for patients
uh whoops sorry
gotta try and use my mouse without
flipping through these screens
okay so if you look they're predicting
people
uh that had no crane and change okay or
very little creative change
this is what they're predicting as a
result and all the people that were most
affected
okay all of them were not predicted
okay so this model is totally
ineffective in doing what it needs to do
which again is back to that value of
what
what we're about in contrast you can see
that the results that were built here
do a pretty decent job of doing it
they're predicting pretty well
the predicted results okay and the
observed results
they're missing some however okay
they're missing some down here
but they're doing pretty well at
predicting across again a small data set
but they're predicting much better than
you're getting out of the current system
and that's what we're after you can look
at the rifle categories as well and see
once again
the predictions here are quite good
compared uh to what they are with the
current system
they're still not uh they're still not
great in the sense that they're doing
perfectly but they're doing much better
and in fact they're tending to over
predict
with only a couple cases of
underpredicting
uh with fewer cases of underpredicting
which is again showing improvements on
this
on this the same thing can be done with
a binary classification predicting
injury
uh and failure um
we're seeing this again improve
performance again not perfect
performance but improved performance
with these results we also can find the
significant predictor so we can give the
clinicians
a sense of where to look in order to
understand again these are models that
we
that are not black boxes that we can go
in and we can look at characteristics
that can help them understand and
communicate with them
um again this is at the design level
communicating with them
what it is that they need to look at
clinically
in order to uh to make these uh make
these decisions
about possible uh adverse surgical
outcomes
okay i'm gonna summarize then and say
data science as we've seen it integrates
disciplines and technologies to solve
problems and extract knowledge from data
so it's
it's all about this interdisciplinary
integrative approach
which is after real problems real pro
important problems
the four plus one model as i said i
think we've
we've put together a way to think about
data science that helps guide us and
when we're doing data science
if we think about these four areas as we
go into a data science problem
always centered on practice what the
problem is
then we've got a good framework for
approaching uh
solving true data science problems okay
i think i've got 10 minutes left as was
asked
so um i guess i'd like to
turn it back over jack i can see the
questions or
you can
do what you want or would you
how would you like to do it jack don
firstly thank you so much for uh
that's a great overview of data science
and why we want to practice this
um we do have a couple of questions that
are are out there let me just before we
begin those those are a little more
technical
let me uh just ask you a couple more
broader based questions before we begin
um i sort of go i think i know the
answer
to this but i wanted to get your
impressions about this is data science
itself
an insular discipline that is is you
know can one do data science for the
sake of data science
or is it inherently a multi-disciplinary
effort
uh data science is inherently a
multi-disciplinary effort
uh you you really i mean in our world in
the in the world that we're
dealing with now where data science is
so important
it has to be multi-disciplinary it has
to bring all these characteristics that
we've talked about here
uh you can't be i mean don't get me
wrong they're people who can be very
specialized and and that's where a lot
of quote data scientists have been
thought to come from
we're very specialized in both the
analytics or very specialized in the
systems area
but that's not going to do it in a real
data science problem and i hope i've
illustrated that
you've got to be someone who can
actually do for instance not only the
analytics but
the design component as well and your
team has to have
that those pieces on it if you want to
if the problem is so complex that you
need very very specialized people in
analytics then you've got to have
equivalent nightmare specialized people
in design
to help you put this together so data
science as we as we think of practicing
it now is very much
this interdisciplinary piece yeah i
think this kind of leads into
the second part of that question which
was what sort of attributes are
kind of necessary for people who are
interested in beginning careers
as data scientists oh wow um
yeah this is this is a fun question and
i guess uh
i could throw it back to you as much as
uh yeah
but it's a i think i think a guy like
you jack is a perfect example i don't
know
since you were complimentary in the
beginning i think somebody who is uh
who is invested in a problem like you
were invested in the brain
who's just really looking at it and
saying good gosh
i want to understand these these
characteristics and i want to really
understand
uh what's happening in this field uh and
to do that
you're just naturally going to be led to
all four of those areas
by you know by your inquisitiveness
about the fundamental question that
you're asking
so i think somebody who comes to data
science there's got to be someone who's
who's in inquisitive curious and wanting
to really make a difference
in an area that is important uh
you know and and as a result they are
going to buy
that very by that drive that they have
toward
solving that be driven to these these
four areas that i've described and and
wanting to understand them so that they
can really go after that problem well
that's great and um one final portion of
this before we get into some more
technical
questions about things is uh you are the
co-director of an nih ctsa
program and i'm curious what does data
science have to offer the biosciences
from the point of view of translational
research in terms of education
and training oh in terms of education
training i was going to say if you if
you stopped before that i think it's
everything it offers everything to
translation i think you can't do
translation without doing data science
i agree but yeah uh i well
in terms of education we're trying to uh
provide uh
you know i shouldn't say we're trying we
have provided a number of what we call
learning shots
uh that are giving you you know
more deep dives and there in fact we
have one that's specifically on this
four plus one model
a colleague of mine did and then i for
instance did one on analytics
uh and so we give deep dives in each of
these areas we go
we go in more depth to describe
characteristics of
of each of these four areas and so
that's what we've been trying to do is
to build
uh these learning shots out and then we
we have others that are just
again versions of my talk here today
they're
they're case studies i gave you two
quick overview
kind of case studies uh but we i have a
colleague for instance and she's built
one that's on exactly that environmental
enteropathy
she's done a full up uh uh you know uh
30 or 40 minute presentation on just
that describing data science for that
problem
instead of the whatever i spent today
five to ten minutes i don't know what it
was
uh so yeah so it's all of that together
that's trying i think to give
people that are interested in
translational health science i've given
them a sense of how data science is so
critical to their uh to their mission
that's great so uh some of the questions
that you're rolling in here you can take
a look at these yourself if you want to
see the uh
some of the the language here but in the
discussion of the enteropathy was kind
of interesting you kind of
mentioned uh several techniques um for
each of the outcomes
and how were you cho how are these
chosen
um and based on predictive power for
example
um and another part of this question
that somebody else is asking is uh how
is the robustness defined
yeah um let me answer your first part
and then i'll try and deal with
the second one um so the uh
the the first thing is is that you know
you bear in mind this is like any talk
that you're uh that you get
you know i've never been to a conference
where
uh you know you don't get a talk where
it appears like uh
you know they had this incredibly
complicated problem and boy they were
brilliant had these uh
these uh these techniques and got this
great answer and gosh wasn't that
wonderful what you're missing is of
course all the uh
the blood sweat and tears that went on
to try and figure all that out and
how this went together which you know
and it was all there don't get me wrong
i'm not gonna pretend uh we're uh
you know what can i say we're not uh jon
snow
we didn't we didn't come up with these
uh this brilliant insight
we there was a lot of work to try
different techniques out here jack
you've got a bit of more of that at that
last thing that i gave on
the the surgical safety because i i put
up there the list of things that we were
trying
and some of which didn't work very well
at all and
that's really the way it was with the
environmental and interrupting we tried
a bunch of different things
and even to this day i mean this problem
we're still working on versions of these
problems
right now and it's and we continually
try stuff
uh and we're trying newer things we're
trying different versions of things
the nice thing about the world now is
that as i say we've got a lot of
hardware and software that we can just
spin up and try
quickly and throw it out when it doesn't
work
so that's good uh the bad thing is that
we've got a lot of these things that we
can try
so you've got a lot of things to choose
from so it can just frustrate the heck
out of you
so you do have to be clever about how
you're doing it and you do have to take
a a
you know i'll say a scientific approach
and
pick the ones that make the most sense
for your particular problem
yeah and uh somebody else was asking
about uh a little bit about the
conditions that one might use to kind of
decide whether or not one should use a
say a traditional linear regression or a
gradient boosting style approach or
maybe an alternative might be uh whether
or not you're going to use any sort of
uh penalized regression type of approach
you know what sort of things might you
look at in terms of the conditions of
the data or is it just you know you
should try all these things and find the
one that works best
no it's more it's more than that because
frankly it's kind of what i said about
this interpretability thing
the one that works best may not be uh
best for your
your problem domain because i mean that
last one as i say
it was extremely important for us that
the the surgeons in this case
understood uh what it was that they
could use
in order to make these determinations
because
it was important for them to know that
since that it isn't a matter of just
plugging this in and getting an answer
out they want to basically
look at these characteristics of these
patients and themselves make a
determination that's
frankly why they get paid the big bucks
is they want they
they want they they need to make
decisions about their patients
and they need to understand what it is
that this thing is giving them this
thing being the data science
uh solution that is telling them hey
this is a probability of this
uh it's got to give them uh that answer
um i didn't answer the question on
robustness
that i gave the robustness thing i
mentioned with regard to uh
this uh color balancing and that means
that uh
it's robust i can give it uh different
values
i i you know different ways in which
we've done that color balancing
and it's still going to produce an
answer that uh
that is that is good it's gonna produce
a very nice answer
so it's when i say that i mean it's it's
uh
not sensitive it's it's not terribly
sensitive it's sensitive
but it's not strongly sensitive in the
sense the results change dramatically
for the worse as a result of doing a
different color balancing
uh and in general that's what we mean
and when we talk about robustness
it's defined formally in statistics and
concerning you know extreme values
and that's pretty much where we're how
we're defining it here as well
uh a little bit more exacting with
regard to this color balancing stuff
um and and okay gradient boosting over
uh traditional regression
yeah the gradient boosting over
traditional regression
the gradient boosting is something that
we can we can understand
uh and and look at the character look at
the features
give the uh the surgeons again those
kind of things
and gradient boosting has the advantage
that it's taking
uh results from extreme uh points it's
taking these uh
these unusual points and it's learning
from those and whereas
traditional regression doesn't do that
it's just a it's a batch approach
and that and that's why it turned out
gradient boosting was
was much more effective in this uh
because it could learn that way
um so that's the reason that it was used
well with that i want to thank you don
for giving us a fantastic
overview on data science as a discipline
as a collaborative space as a team sport
and some of the important uh elements
that make up
modern data science uh and as it applies
to biomedicine
i so thank you again and i want to
encourage all of you to
uh join us once again next friday at uh
12 noon
eastern time and 9 00 a.m pacific for
our next in the series
of biomedical data science seminar
series
so thank you once again everybody have a
great weekend thank you
bye